dozens of metro officers were honored
and recognized for their bravery and for
saving lives now aside from the actual
awards some of the incidents were
recognized were really just going above
and beyond the call of duty christian
gossetus joining us now in studio with
really some pretty inspiring stories
kristin that's right we're talking about
40 members of our local law enforcement
that were recognized today and we're
talking about captains lieutenants and
even the nevada state police
it was a difficult day and probably one
of the toughest calls i've ever been on
and probably ever will be trooper rhian
brams can't forget a tough situation she
was recently called to assist a teenager
steps away from jumping off a building
that de-escalation is what the trooper
is being honored for accomplishing the
words are so difficult to find in that
situation
you just want to keep talking and keep
her engaged with you
the trooper is one of several members of
southern nevada's law enforcement
honored during wednesday's commendation
ceremony for bravery and their service
in seven different categories i just
thought it was just going to be another
stop that you know i was going to
write a citation for for officer daniel
you that traffic stop uncovered two
handguns someone else's id and passport
cash and a body of a missing person i
was out there protecting the community
doing my job what i had to do
de-escalation toy community service and
even a life-saving award were bestowed
on these men and women as their friends
and family watched ever so proudly each
one telling us their biggest honor is
being able to serve and protect the las
vegas community the biggest honor for me
is to see the police officers up there
on stage this is something you're right
that will stay within the rest of their
career
they should know that their hard work
matters
well those honored today tell me it's a
reminder of why they chose this career
and how honored they are to serve
christian casa is live local now